[Music]
the village of kamikatsu is special
not for its tea fields or idyllic
mountains or peaceful historic homes
it's known for something it doesn't have
kamikatsu as a town produces almost no
trash
[Music]
kamikatsu has a population of roughly 1
500 people and in the 1990s was doing
nearly no recycling
burning all that garbage created carbon
dioxide emissions that became dangerous
and the nature around them was suffering
so a decision was made
kamikatsu had to change
this was the start of their path towards
zero waste and a new way of living
in
effectively what zero waste here means
is that there's no such thing as
throwing something in the trash
everything has to get recycled
and in the beginning it was difficult
for everyone
like mr takuya takaichi he's a shop
owner in kamikazu
[Music]
are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that classification system she's talking
about is the key to kamikaze's success
and it is aggressive
there are 45 categories of recyclables
[Music]
[Music]
the list it goes on there's 35 more
slowly what was originally this huge
burden became a way of life in kamikatsu
people began looking at trash
differently
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's important to recognize that
kamikaze is a small town it is not like
new york or london the rules are not the
same but there is a constant and that's
people they can change
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
money
it's everywhere
but what happens when your bills get old
they need to be replaced by new ones
that means old cash needs to be
destroyed
a lot of cash
this is not however the story of money
growing on trees but of trees
growing out of money well more like
vegetables
we are here at the federal reserve bank
in new orleans and this is where we
shred millions of dollars
my name is dean mortha i'm the lead
business analyst for cash services here
at the new orleans bed we are the
nation's bank our job is to make sure
that we have a supply of currency
also part of that is to ensure that we
remove unfit old dirty currency from
circulation so here on average we shred
about six million dollars in dirty money
every day
this could be for any number of reasons
it could be because the note has rips in
it holes in it tears in it
it could have tape on it it could have
graffiti written all over it we don't
want that note going back into
circulation if it has any sort of those
qualities will be shredded
what we used to do is take all of these
currency shreds and they would just wind
up his waste going to a landfill
now through a lot of work and effort we
finally figured out a way where we can
take these shreds and ultimately recycle
them
so all that green leaves the fed and
heads to a compost facility where it
turns into something quite useful
what you're looking at right now is 24
million dollars but the soil that it
creates will be priceless
my name is jonathan christian
we turn cash into soil
it is definitely one of our secret
ingredients
it's little in content but it's huge in
what it provides
[Music]
currency that's deemed unfit it's
brought to our facility at wood
materials
from there we go through a simple
composting process where we convert that
into a healthy soil
our compost is used primarily by urban
farmers in the greater new orleans area
one of these farmers is simon minash and
this is a million dollar farm
we are making fresh local food
accessible
in new orleans
we've grown veggies herbs cucumbers
tomatoes and peppers the vegetables we
grow here are made out of composted cash
it is very fulfilling to
be growing using a material that would
otherwise go to waste
one man's trash is another man's
treasure
and that's the story of how we grow
tomatoes
out of cash
[Music]
haiti is faced with one of the biggest
challenges
environmentally in the world
most people when they see the huge
amount of plastic or huge amount of
trash out in the community it
discouraged them and they try to drive
away from it
that's why i took it upon myself to try
to make a change
[Music]
i know i can't do it all but if i can
only take one bottle out of that trash
that's one bottle less prevented from
going into the ocean
[Music]
the plastic bank is a company that pays
people to collect plastic within the
community preventing the plastic from
going into the ocean
the vast majority of the plastic that
are entering the ocean is coming from
poor countries
in order to make a change we have to
attack the problem
and the problem is poverty
the top priority i would say in haiti
would be to put food on the table
people doesn't have the proper knowledge
of how to properly dispose of any waste
[Music]
basically the plastic bank is cleaning
up our environment and at the same time
alleviating poverty
i was born in haiti
did all my studies in the united states
i never understood what recycling meant
until
i came here and realized how important
it was
that's when it dawned to me that i have
to make a change i have to tell people i
have to make sure that people understand
that they cannot just throw this stuff
on on the ground we have to be more
responsible
each day
these collectors they go out and collect
this plastic
after the plastic has been collected
it's taken to a center where it's
weighed
and in return you can get cash or other
services for that plastic
from there we do our own inspection and
get ready for transport
my daily work consists of
going around the centers you know making
sure the managers are treating the
collectors right
going around to the collective sites
making sure that the plastic that they
collect get transported in a sufficient
time so they don't have to wait on their
money
in a month we collect the mass volume of
plastic but you'll be amazed how much
plastic we collect
plastic bank has 30 collection centers
all throughout haiti
each center has
over 75 collectors this center right
here in a month we could make at least
19 000 pounds
we're employing people who are in need
at the same time we're taking more
plastic out of the environment that's
why companies are willing to pay a
little bit more because we're creating a
positive change in haiti
[Music]
what drives me to keep doing this every
day is the people that i see doing it
every day they're my greatest
inspiration because you have to be
strong in order to live to survive here
you have to be a fighter
we are in a really bad environmental
state in haiti so
whatever we can do to get it done is
what we do
this is a global issue
we have one planet which is our home
everyone needs to put together and try
to
solve this problem
[Music]
you